c'est ton mariage ça ouais c'est mon
mariage d'ailleurs tu avais pas voulu
venir pourquoi tu avais pas voulu venir
à quoi
bon la veille de mon
mariage je reçois des coups quand je te
dis des coups sur tout mon corps
c'estàdire que quand je me déshabille je
suis bleu quand je dois changer les
tenues pendant le
mariage ma sœur voit tout
ça je lui ai dit surtout tuas encore le
temps pour tout annuler bon ben elle
voulait pas j'ai eu le choix et j'ai
fait le
mauvais quand on est rentré du mariage
j'étais devenue sa propriété il m'a dit
maintenant tu parles plus tu t
[Musique]
t'écoutes
Bic supress and and mur other
[Musique]
people
je rencontre le père de mes futurs
enfants en allant au
travail j'ai la trentaine je suis au
sommet de ma
forme il est avec sa grosse voiture il
descend de la voiture il la laisse comme
ça en plein milieu puis il vient à ma
rencontre déjà surprise parce que c'est
drôle comme attitude mais ça fait bad
boy tu vois ah je me suis dit ah c'est
original ça commence comme ça donc je me
laisse aller et puis il m'invite puis je
me dis pourquoi pas c'est c'est un bel
homme le début de relation c'est le
prince charmant il est il est jovial
c'est un jleman sourire
cheese il m'ouvre la porte de sa voiture
c'est des cadeaux à hautrance des
voyages on a beaucoup
voyagé moi je le vois oui il est grand
il est charmant première vue il a l'air
d'être
normal et donc je présente à ma
meilleure amie
je lui présente puis après il s'en va et
on en discute je lui explique comment il
est et
elle ne le ressent pas de la même
façon moi j'ai un regard extérieur donc
moi je lui dis ce que je ressens ce que
je vois après elle en fait ce qu'elle
veut quelque partielle qui vit qui vit
le truc donc je la laisse vivre son son
truc j'étais censée passer l'après-midi
avec elle elle est venu me récupérer au
bout de 30 minutes il est venu me
chercher quand lui il avait décidé en
fait nous on avait pas fini et comme je
suis très proche de de cet ami elle l'a
pas compris en fait parce que d'habitude
ça se passe pas comme
ça moi je lui fais attention ça se passe
bien c'est je suis contente pour toi tu
as ça t'aide aussi à avancer
mais
mais ça va l'air d'être quelqu'un de
très possessif fais
attention je dis non tuabuses il y a
jamais personne qui est parfait attends
il est charmant il m'amène il revient me
chercher il pense à moi il m'appelle 36
fois pour moi c'est c'est
génial quand ma mère et mon père sont
rencontré je devais avoir
ouais 10 11 ans
elle m'a juste dit un jour que bah j'ai
rencontré quelqu'un et ça devait
vraiment être sérieux pour qu'elle me le
présente juste à côté de chez ma mère il
y avait un grand parc et euh on s'était
toutous les trois réunis là et je me
souviens qu'il m'avait porté sur ses
épaules qu'on avait rigolé qu'il avait
l'air gentil et que ma mère sourait
beaucoup quand je présente
ossan ça se passe bien et je suis
contente je suis heureuse je me dis ah
bon ça peut le faire il faisait les 400
coups en je leur l' laissé je leur
laissa les clés de mon appart ils
allaient un peu partout enfin ils
étaient tout le temps vadrouill dehors
j'avais pas les détails de leur histoire
il nous arrivait de sortir ensemble
comme un jour de l'an on avait passé une
super soirée avec des amis à eux dans un
loft c'était génial
quoi bon il me semble que ce soir-là il
y avait déjà eu une scène de jalousie
enfin ça commençait déjà à être un peu
tendu entre
eux
est-ce que tu te Soues la première fois
où il a levé la
main
alors tu sais j'ai un quand quand quand
je parle de lui ça me fait comme un un
trou noir il y a des fois
oùou la violence elle a été de plus en
plus fréquente ben l'annonce de ma
première
grossesse quand on était pas d'accord et
ben j'essayais toujours de lui faire
comprendre que non il y avait d'autres
manières de voir les choses et là ça ça
ça l' amené à une colère
[Musique]
noire la première fois qu'il a été
agressif avec moi je sors d'un d'un
tournage je vois 50 appels en absence
j'écoute les messages ils sont de plus
en plus agressifs et du coup je m'énerve
et comme à l'époque j'ai un tempérament
bien trempé et ben je ne l'appelle pas
donc je décide de rentrer chez moi et je
le trouve devant la porte de chez
moi tout de suite c'est je prends soin
de toi mais tu ne t'en rends pas compte
pourquoi tu veux pas queon prenne soin
de toi et là ben je me calme j'ouvre ma
porte et il rentre et puis je suis avec
lui un moment donné je vais aller dans
la cuisine et quand je reviens il me
prend le coussin et il me le il me le
balance à la tête mais violemment
vraiment sur mon visage c'est la
première fois où je me rends compte son
regard change et que je ressens une
espèce d'agressivité en
fait là je le regarde et je pense qu'il
réalise que je me rends compte et d'un
seul coup il il se calme mais c'était
violent on pense que c'est
une querelle ou un amour passionnel
fusionnel des fois où c'est un peu
intense donc on se dit bon bah c'est
leur histoire quoi et puis bah ma sœur
il lui faut peut-être ça parce qu'elle
elle a une forte personnalité donc on se
dit c'est normal jusqu'au moment où vous
voyez le premier
bleu le premier
plâtre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le jour de son mariage personne le sait
mais madame elle était couverte de bleu
hein donc on tout allait bien tout le
monde était jovial tout se passait bien
mais non c'est pas vrai c'est c'est faux
c'est complètement
faux là j'ai mal partout là ça se voit
pas
[Musique]
et en fait j'ai eu le choix et j'ai fait
le
mauvais c'est drôle parce que
normalement un mariage qui est censé
être joyeux et alors que pour moi ça a
été le début du commencement de la fin
en
fait
votre première plainte c'était le 9 août
2011 il vous a poussé frappé au visage
il vous a fait sauter une dent euh il
vous a craché dessus insulté il vous a
menacé de vous envoyer du monde pour
vous péter les jambes et vous mettre en
fauteuil roulant et là vous aviez dans
la dans les bras votre enfant de 17 mois
oui exactement et là vous avez contusion
de la face fracture de la dent et du
bras droit retentissement psychologique
de 3 sur 7 c'est beaucoup 4 jours
d'incapacité de travail tout à
fait et c'est monté crchendo ça allait
tous les de TR jours c'était oui toute
façon une sale
de toute façon tu as de la chance
d'être tomberé sur moi tu veux faire tu
veux faire ta belle je vais te défigurer
il il me disait ça à longueur de
temps
peut-être 3 qu jours après il a commencé
par me pousser alors que j'étais en
enfin j'étais enceinte et il me balance
une
droite et je suis choquée
hein quand il y a de la violence je
faisais juste attention au bruit en fait
au type de bruit qui se
passait le moindre coupou bruit je
l'entendais et genre j'ai arrêtais de
bouger
pour voir si il allait se passer quoi
après et des fois j'avais mon téléphone
qui était allumé avec le numéro des
urgences au cas
[Musique]
où enin la violence dans laquelle il
baignait enfin moi j'avais du
mal arrivé de parler à ma niè m'a dit
bon ça va je gère des fois il me fait
peur mais les cris tout ça enfin des
fois j'ai du mal à dormir le lendemain
j'ai
école
c'était pendant la nuit ça criait moi
j'avais cours le
lendemain j'étais énervé saoulé fatigué
je me suis énervée j'avais un verre
d'eau je suis allé dans le salon et je
lui ai jeté à la
tête il s'est levé il a commencé à
avancer vite vers
moi ma mère m'a littéralement poussé
dans ma chambre elle a fermé la porte et
elle s'est mis devant la porte donc je
voyais plus ce qui se passait mais
j'entendais que ça tapait contre la
porte fort et les
hurlements je l'ai haï quand je l'ai vu
la fois
d'après je pensais à la fois qui serait
celle de trop et qui nous enlèverait
notre
mère
[Musique]
il était parti au sport donc je je pant
qu'il est pas là je me dis ben tiens je
vais faire tourner une machine en fait
et dans le sa de sport je trouve un
string des bouces d'oreilles il rentre
il arrive il mange et puis il voulait
avoir alors je vais être cru un rapport
avec moi je l'ai regardé je dit cou m
j'auris pas de rapport sexuel avec toi
je suis enceinte et après ça c'est trop
pour moi en fait là c'était même plus à
moi que je pensais c'était à l'enfant il
a pas supporté il s'est relevé et d'un
seul coup il s'est retourné il dit je te
demande de faire l'amour avec toi tu dis
non et d'un seul coup je me suis pris un
point deux points et je suis tombée du
coup je me suis traîné jusqu'à la salle
de bain et j'ai fermé la porte j'étais
par terre et je me suis accroché au
lavabo je me suis
relevé et quand j'ai vu mon visage dans
le miroir j'ai poussé un
hurlement c'est comme si j'étais plus
là c'était pas
mort j'arrive chez
elle je la vois en
sang dit mais tu vas crever quoi
enfin à un moment
[Musique]
euh alors là vous êtes encore enceinte
euh vous avez reçu deux coup de PO au
visage front et pomette droite vous êtes
tombé sur un meuble au niveau du ventre
une première fois vous avez tenté de
vous relever après avoir rampé par terre
en pleurant mais votre compagnon vous a
refait chuter au sol vous êtes tombé sur
le ventre une seconde fois vous êtes
alors en faire dans la salle de bain
vous avez été hospitalisé opéré à la
suite de ces
coups lui a dit qu'il avait reconnu une
gifle je me souviens que j'étais chez ma
grand-mère pendant une semaine je pense
pendant les vacances et ma mère elle
m'avait envoyé un SMS qui disait ne
rentre
pas sur le coup j'ai pas compris mais
mon père était
bizarre et je me souviens qu'il est
rentré chez ma grand-mère il s'est assis
à côté de moi on a par
et un moment il m'a dit ta mère tu peux
pas aller la voir au début j'ai pas
compris
et il m'a dit que elle s'était fait
taper et sur le coup j'ai pas
[Musique]
compris je suis extrêmement buté donc
j'ai réussi à rentrer à la maison au
bout de quelques jours même pas un ou de
jours et elle a été défigurée
elle avait l' qui se fermait elle avait
la mâchoire
[Musique]
démise et ces plaintes sont étayées par
un certificat médical et là c'est ce
certificat médical fait état d'une
fracture complexe du plancher de
l'orbite droite d'une contusion au bras
droit et à la région frontale droite et
évidemment un retentissement
psychologique qui justifie lui
psychologique 15 jours d'ITT 15 jours d'
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup c'est
c'est
grave ce qui caractérise l'emprise dans
le dossier de lid c'est le fait qu'elle
porte plainte et qu'elle retire ses
plaintes et ce sont des plaintes qui
sont pour des faits
graves je suis venue dans votre service
lundi 8 août pour déposer plainte contre
Monsieur pour des violences
conjugales je vous informe vouloir
retirer ma plainte je vous informe que
je viens de mon pleing gré et que je
n'ai subi aucune pression ni
menace quand elle est parti déposer des
mains courantes ou porter plainte je l'
accompagna jusqu'au commissariat pour la
[Musique]
soutenir je l' accompagné porter plainte
c'est vrai et bah souvent retirait sa
plainte j'ai déposé plainte dans votre
service contre mon
excjoint
je souhaite retirer ma plainte je n'ai
subi aucune contrainte pour retirer ma
plainte je n'ai rien d'autre à
déclarer et puis à chaque fois que je la
revoyais qu'il y avait des bleus ou
qu'il y avait un coup ou une dent moins
je lui disais mais elle me disait oui
non mais je parle je parle enfin oui tu
parles mais à un moment c'est pas
suffisant donc je disais mais tu fais
n'importe quoi comment tu veux que la
situation change ça changera pas si si
tu retires ta plainte à chaque
fois
elle est sous cette emprise elle veut
absolument donner une chance au père de
ses enfants elle ne réussit pas à se
dire que définitivement cet Hommel est
violent et qu'elle doit se séparer de
lui à chaque fois que ma sœur retire sa
plainte ça me tape sur le système parce
que je me dis que ce ne sera pas réglé
et qu'il faut des
traces c'est elle qui vit la chose moi
je peux pas la forcer à maintenir une
plainte si elle est
après quatre fois je suis partie porter
plainte et quatre fois je les ai
[Musique]
retiré j'avais honte j'étais gênée déjà
on n'est pas très bien accueilli et puis
en plus souvent ils ont tendance à dire
encore
une donc déjà c'est pas très agréable à
entendre au commissariat il y a un truc
qui me fait souvent rire c'est que quand
on retire sa plainte on nous demande on
nous fait signer un papier comme quoi on
on retire pas la plainte par contrainte
mais c'est c'est c'est tellement
ridicule bien sûr qu'une femme elle la
retire par
peur c'est c'est incompréhensible une
femme sousemprise elle a peur bien sûr
que si elle vient retirer sa plante
c'est par
[Musique]
contrainte en fait on se sent impuissant
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire à notre
niveau si la personne même elle a pas de
déclic et elle décide pas de partir vous
êtes pas collé à la personne tout le
temps enfin j'ai pété un câ je crois que
j'étais je l'ai envoyé chier pour la
première fois je l'ai insulté j'ai hurlé
dans ma voiture j'ai je lui ai dit
d'aller se faire
j'avais jamais insulé ma
[Musique]
sœur pendant un an et demi on ne s'est
plus adresser la
[Musique]
parole j'étais persuadée qu'elle
arriverait jamais à s'en détacher alors
qu'on sait qu'on devrait que c'est
toxique que c'est mal mais que on trouve
des excuses encore et encore alors qu'il
devrait pas y en
[Musique]
avoir après les
engueelades et ben il est en mode
toujours oui mais pourquoi tu m'énerves
c'est de ta
faute pourquoi tu pourquoi tu me pousses
à bout et bon je me dis
ça se trouve c'est moi qui le pousse
inconsciemment je dois être quelqu'un de
difficile à
vivre puis il a été d'une extrême mais
extrême douceur après mais on aurait dit
que c'était pas la même personne je
pense que je ne suis pas parti parce
qu'il m'a réconforté ce réconfort que
j'ai pas l'habitude d'avoir ça a été
waouh je me suis dit j'ai pas connu ça
moi enfant personne s'intéressa à moi
étant une enfant placée j'ai j'ai pas eu
énormément d'attention ou d'amour et
donc dans les familles d'accueil c'est
pas si
[Musique]
évident j'ai eu une enfance très très
compliquée ma mère était malade
elle était
[Musique]
dépressive d'près ce que j'ai pris elle
se serait
suicidée on
était un peu livré à nous-même car mon
père était quelqu'un de très très
actif enfin il aidait pas mal les gens
au détriment de ses enfants mais bon
avec son grand cœur je pense que c'était
pas fait de manière volontaire je pense
qu'il se rendait pas bien compte qu'il
avait deux petites filles qui avaient
besoin de lui
quoi il nous mettait à gauche e à droite
et puis à un moment donné ça n'allait
plus il y a eu des signalements et puis
de là on a été
[Musique]
placé à l'adolescence c'était compliqué
parce que il y a eu des transitions
c'està-dire que j'ai été placé j'ai été
récupéré j'ai été replacé j'ai été
récupéré et
entretemps j'avais une vie quoi d'un
endroit à l'autre et ma vie était
chamboulée complètement
perturbée
donc l'adolescence difficile parce que
j'en voulais beaucoup à mon père et du
coup bah c'est là que j'ai commencé à à
connaître le monde extérieur si tu
veux à l'époque je suis danseuse je fais
du théâtre je fais des figurations je
fais des pubs je fais du
manquina a de tout hein et bon je fais
la fête je vis tout marche bien il me
manque que l'amour et puis je tombe sur
sur
monsieur je suis parti au bout de 5 ans
ça a été
dur mais si j'étais restée je serais
morte si j'avais pas été au bout je
serais
morte les
violence qu'elle a subi aurait pu
effectivement la conduire à mourir
[Musique]
apparemment il y a eu un il y a eu un
quak raté puisque la victime n'a pas été
prévenue de
l'audience je m'attendais à être
là je m'attendais à être
là à le regarder
je suis pas quelqu'un qui fuit les
problèmes je les affronte
elle était déçu de ne pas voir été pas
avoir été convoqué elle se sentait
bafoué dans ses droits elle ne
comprenait même pas que ça puisse se
passer comme ça moi j'ai jamais vu
[Musique]
ça et du coup il aura 6 mois avec surc
moi ça me tue
ça dit quelle
justice aujourd'hui ma mère elle a une
ordonnance restrictive par rapport à lui
mais c'est un bout de papier
littéralement déjà faut la renouveler
constamment donc pour moi c'est une
vaste
blague
j'ai toujours l'impression de revivre la
même chose c'est comme à chaque fois
j'ai toujours la même la même les mêmes
angoisses j'ai une boule au ventre le
fait d'arriver de le croiser de croiser
son regard ça me dérange
faut pas croiser son regard vous
protéger faut pas le regarder et on va
pas s'approcher
[Musique]
de qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de
l'audience un peu frustré déjà ça
commence P à l'arrivée quand la salle
d'attente moi je comprends pas qu'on
soit dans dans la même salle d'attente
quoi juste la présence retourner en
arrière c'est c'est recommencer à chaque
fois c'est douloureux quoi c'est moi je
je suis parti de l'avant mais chaque
fois que je reviens ici c'est toujours
la même chose j'ai je revis ce que j'ai
vécu c'est c'est dur m moi qui me
considère moins fragilisé qu'avant c'est
c'est toujours aussi difficile pour moi
c'est compliqué et en même temps je suis
un peu frustrée comme il y a que les
avocats qui parlent j'avais des choses à
dire j'aurais voulu être entendu j'ai
cette espèce de de frustration et du
coup ça m'occasionne une crainte je me
dis ils ont peut-être pas compris ils
ont peut-être pas saisi parce que j'ai
pas pu m'exprimer en
fait j'ai hâte que tout ça finisse ça
fait quand même pas mal d'années oui je
comprends
tes courageuse c'est un combat
[Musique]
ça c'était une belle
passe presque
[Musique]
ouais c'est ça le
basket allez les filles
réveillez-vous après 10 ans de violence
on a envie de tourner la page on a envie
d'avancer on a des objectifs
on se reconstruit parce que comme je
disais l'emprise on sort pas seul moi
j'en suis sortie à travers un groupe
j'ai suivi 50 de
thérapie pour apprendre à retrouver
l'estime mon
estime je suis très fière de ma sœur
elle revient de très très
loin on se bat aujourd'hui pour donner
l'exemple pour montrer qu'on peut s'en
sortir avec de la volonté avec de
l'amour heureusement qu'on a l'amour de
nos enfants et voilà à quoi on est
réduit une mère de famille qui a plein
d'enfants ça cuisine elle est sans
dessus
dessous bon souvenir de Noël et du coup
j'ai repris mes études j'ai eu mon
diplôme et je suis rentrée directement à
la radio où j'ai fait une émission un
concept qui parle de ce que toutes les
femmes
ressentent pour qu'elle puisse
s'exprimer ce que moi j'avais pas pu
faire en fait
aujourd'hui ouais je suis complètement
Fiè d'elle c'est une battente elle s'est
battu c'est vraiment une W roman
vraiment je suis passée par les procès
j'ai eu la pension alimentaire qui ne
m'a pas été versée je me suis battu je
l'ai eu j'ai eu l'interdiction de sortir
de territoire j'ai fait tout ce qu'il y
avait à faire avec un visage abîmé vous
savez pas comment c'est difficile de
regarder les gens quand même quand on va
acheter une baguette dans la rue on nose
pas lever les yeux sur vous je pense
queaujourd'hui l'emprise elle est plus
que finie niveau mais ça a été un long
chemin une longue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bataille